hello and welcome to see your playing I
am long launching something a little bit
okay yeah I place the Kings gambit okay
check yeah fairly normal lose let's see
what is he doing you see form probably
goes for see 490 6426 maybe em so until
I think after castles I can take Queen
you six year I don't know this is
probably just trading things I can take
e cigs actually take a fall which is
probably equal hmm anyway let's not
think for too long I often take 22 too
much time trying to check especially
against somewhat bad openings like the
Kings gambit and instead just plain ol
moves would be would be better and don't
don't lose that much time try to do
something that isn't there
you
mmm ok so a three before is the idea i
guess i can still check and go for 93 m
don't have to go back necessarily so
check check
so King f one night where d3 and
probably d3 okay again just normal moves
nothing fancy
so the chick doesn't do much just go
back yeah it's that what is that is set
equal or do I and have some ideas have
the same probably equal
taking b6 spoon okay
hmm ok I rupee a this is really name
hmm not sure though what else to do come
on let's play it a little bit cuckoo
okay a good square for this if I go here
and the tail checking this and maybe 97
trying to get to the d5 pawn
okay so check here check to be too
might have joins us and causes it off is
slightly weird coordination here take
this check check so we can take you to
now I think yep and step up
we still rather draw cannot win the pawn
unfortunately the only have two is is
always time morning presenting that okay
so we should check
check
yeah not much that I can do check draw
our third maybe you can find it suks one
check
don't quite get this get this play but
anyway check draw ahead hmm why should I
take it but I cannot lose any more of
course it's dead but
game yeah okay I could have taken it of
course yeah so what about this game yet
did have chances after the opening
probably not I wonder what was wrong I
can't go clean at five years and then
can so long yeah Queenie six was
unnecessary after that like it's already
had a lot better okay I was D Phi for
some moves that irritated me here but I
can occur so long Wow check in black
wins ok so after white has spent 15
seconds black has a winning position
already but I didn't didn't see it with
queen of five after that yes it's equal
check yeah thought maybe I can do
something here it's probably not d 5 is
not not dead week yeah whenever the king
is on front of a deep on its it's often
more than more weakness and strength
this pawn so this is what I was hoping
for but it simply didn't didn't get
enough here check this is what the
engine wants to play with this idea in
their zone hmm ok
nope didn't Sierra check check check
well here seems to be maybe still
holding difficult and make any headway
but it seems what the engine wants to do
something else even here whoopsie to
which it takes it and at the same time
threatens this this actually wins the
pawn ok if he goes here I go back yeah
so I still had chances in this position
which I didn't didn't take ok thanks for
watching